[Musique]
le premier marché pays de saint-andré
s'est déroulée ce dimanche 9 octobre au
parc du colosse un marché qui propose
aux consommateurs des produits agricoles
authentiques et de qualité mais aussi un
contact direct avec les producteurs sur
la tornade différents produits et à des
produits de saison comme la pastèque
après il ya des prêtres destitué dépit
monde exprimant un peu de tout et
notamment au match point dans ce sont
les producteurs qui vendent leurs
produits de la jambe
[Musique]
ils viennent de plus en plus je pense
que la journée n'est pas terminée
et puis mais ça devrait continuer dans
ce sens là c'est l'aubaine pour nous moi
c'est uniquement de tomates anciennes
s'est notamment produit et il ya
plusieurs arrêtés comme vous pouvez le
voir sur étalages se sont
les produits en agriculture raisonnée
protection biologique intégrée et là
c'est que des semences biologiques moi
je pense que les consommateurs ont
besoin ça va je commencerai à ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui comment se produit
donc c'est le genre de marché qui à mon
avis devrait se renouveler
souvent on va dire voilà ce que c'est et
développer notre vie en faisant dimanche
et puis comme ça
[Musique]
paie les pots du pays automatiquement
par exemple j'ai été dévalisés
[Musique]
la prochaine fois belge emmènerait plus
jeudi pour voir un petit peu les
différents produits qui existent et puis
les produits surtout locaux aujourd'hui
on mange beaucoup de choses mais on sait
pas l'origine donc on a besoin surtout
avec le temps qui passe de ré de savoir
ce qu'on mange pour sa santé une
convention sera prochainement signée
entre le conseil départemental et la
municipalité de saint-andré afin de
valoriser embellir le parc du colosse
aujourd'hui nous avons une filière de
bois de goyavier que le département a
développé les connaît un vrai succès eh
bien nous souhaitons développer ce
produit doit de gagner sur le site pour
embellir le site du colosse il y aura
l'embellissement le fleurissement il y
aura lie la préservation des espaces
naturels comme le petit étang qui se
situe l'issic est un espace naturel de
qualité
qui sera préservée grâce au partenariat
avec le département rendez vous marchez
pays tous les deuxièmes samedis du mois
à l'espace rabelais dans le bas de la
rivière et le 3 décembre pour un marché
pays exceptionnel au musée de villèle
[Musique]